this podcast and every other podcast I
make is supported by patreon if you want
to throw out the patreon at Dollar you'd
be helping to support these relatively
Niche shows but there are other
memberships that include some special
bonuses too such as completely unedited
q and A's ad free versions of content
unedited versions of shows and even the
ability to play games with me so if you
want to support some independent games
industry podcast check out the link in
the description uh hello everyone I'm
Alana and this is Roger Clark welcome to
another episode of uh video game acting
101 um but Roger you were not initially
a video game actor you have a pretty
long history of a very different kind of
acting for anyone who doesn't know who
you are who are you what do you do where
are you from hello everybody my name is
Roger Clark I'm a professional actor uh
yeah most of you guys probably know me
as Arthur Morgan from Red Dead
Redemption 2 is a blessing in our job uh
it was a real joy to work on but yeah
you're right Elena I started out I
trained in the UK and I started out in
theater I started out in theater
and that eventually migrated towards you
know film and and voice over work and
through voice over I started doing voice
acting and then that led on to
Performance capture for games and stuff
I moved back to the States I was born in
New Jersey and like Ireland yeah
I am initially A Yank yeah no way do you
have a dual citizenship I do yeah
school yeah we were just discussing
before we went live that uh are you
toured and went to Brisbane which is
where I'm from and then I probably may
have seen you perform Macbeth in
Brisbane in 2010 I think it's pretty
likely assuming you were there every
night what world did you play how's
McDuff oh very cool spoilers he kills
MacBeth what no come on 600 years old
but yes he kills Macbeth yeah so that
was a lot of fun we had we I remember we
had to bring these big huge Claymores uh
there were stage Claymores obviously you
know so they weren't sharp but it was
still a real pain trying to get through
customs Australian Customs does not make
things easy oh yeah I remember because I
was coming from Hawaii and I bought this
shell and they were so polite you know
and the Australian migr the immigration
they were polite and he says yeah well
this uh this shell is uh it's illegal to
bring into the country
and uh it's either punishable by a
hundred thousand dollar fine or three
months in prison so I'm just gonna go
and have a little look and talk that's
really good oh my God
yeah he had but he was saying it in the
nicest way possible because of the
inflection at the end you know why is
that [__] inflection at the end it
drives me nuts I I think Aussies are
generally pretty polite and I don't
think that anywhere near as uptight as
your usual like American Immigration I
think they're pretty no they are then
they you know there's it's a wonderful
wonderful place I love the beaches made
it myself yeah appreciate it it was a
lot of hard work yeah a lot of The
Westerns that Dan Hauser recommended to
me when I got the job for Red Dead 2 was
actually an Australian film with Guy
Pearce and Ray Winston uh I think it was
called The Proposition it's set in the
Outback in the 19th century yeah yeah so
technically it's not a West it is a
western but it's set in Australia it's
not very West that's all I know but it
put on the themes and everything it's
it's totally Western and yeah it was
great film to touch on that how did how
did uh how did Arthur Morgan come about
you know you you do have a a history as
a theater actor as we we vaguely covered
how did like does it was it something
you auditioned for did you do the full
accent when you auditioned did you
submit multiple tapes and like how long
does that process take for you to
actually get cost as someone is now
iconic as Arthur Morgan
so I had done game I worked on games
before both as a voice actor and and
with performance capture and I loved
both
but I was particularly fascinated with
performance capture so when I moved back
to New York I let my agent know that and
uh funnily enough this breakdown came
along called Untitled video game project
great I thought oh wow
because as you know I mean they're all
called that in the beginning they don't
say boo about anything
uh I've seen a lot of really funny ones
though that like they're Star Wars Stars
but they really pretend they're not and
so they call like instead of saying Jedi
they'll say like Templar but it's so
clear that it's Star Wars and you're
like come on
but they just swap words around it's
very entertaining when I uh I I loved
gaming and uh I think mocap is
fascinating uh because you know you
don't have to change locations and
you'll be you could be in the jungle in
the morning and you could be in the
desert in the afternoon and you know all
the the only limitation is your
imagination you know that and having a
great animator who can come and help you
by showing you what your environment
actually is because without that it's
it's really difficult to try and pull
something out of literally thin air but
yeah
so to answer your question anyways Alana
yeah I I got the breakdown and my agent
says you like video games don't you and
I was like yeah yeah and it was funny
because I just recently returned to
gaming at the time I bought an Xbox 360
because it had been a while and uh the
fella at GameStop says what's you like I
said oh I like sandbox open world story
driven stuff so he recommended Skyrim
and he recommended Red Dead Redemption
hmm and I just finished Red Dead
Redemption like a week before no way my
first audition for two and I didn't know
it at the time but they did ask me to
show up in cowboy boots with uh and to
prepare a West Texan accent so it was an
in-person audition yes and there was you
what was weird about it is usually you
get the sides in advance but this time
no they wanted you they they said well
give them to you when you show up wow so
you had a character breakdown I imagine
no plot no sides and the sides will be
provided at the audition so they
obviously wanted to see how quickly you
might be able to read a page yeah I
would guess they're worried about leaks
surely with Rockstar oh totally right
but the sides that I ended up having
didn't end up in the game either that
was something that the writer
specifically wrote just for the audition
which is usually the case yeah
uh so it was I remember it well too
because it was Arthur walking or what
was eventually to become Arthur just me
doing some Texas accent at the time and
I'm
in a bar and I'm shooting the [__] with
the bartender who's excited because his
daughter was coming into town he hadn't
seen her for a while
and we're being friendly and then at the
end of this the pages I went well
someone put a pressure on your head so
I'm afraid we uh I'm afraid it's the end
of the road for you now you want to do
this out back whether it be less of a
mess
of course I am and that was it and then
I didn't hear from them for ages and I
was doing the theater down in Florida
when they had a call back for me and but
I couldn't make it and uh because I was
down in Florida oh my God I thought all
that that's it then a couple of weeks
later they checked my Avail again and
then it was a couple of auditions and
then a couple of days in the volume
before an actual contract was offered
wow
then I worked on it for five years at
such a long time I I've always like
we've we've spoken I've spoken to Troy
about this on playwatch listen the
amount of time that you had to do that
game and the amount of rewrites I
imagine that happened in a five-year
process did you ever have any trouble
keeping track of who offer was
um I actually didn't
um because I would be I would I got my
sides as they came you know and and I
once I realized that I was the
protagonist of the next Red Dead game I
was a little nervous I won't be honest I
won't lie because
I was such a huge fan of John Marston
and I knew how much he was loved by the
fan base and uh and you know I remember
when no no offense to the actor who
played him but I remember when I took
you any spoilers but when you take over
his Jack and the epilogue you're like
yeah I felt the same way yeah I missed
John yeah and I knew that's what they're
gonna think as soon as they found out
about Arthur
are they say that was my suspicion I
don't think that happened
well when the first trailer introducing
Arthur came out there was a bit of that
okay
just got overshadowed really fast I
don't I don't I don't doubt that you
would remember that I have no
recollection of that happening I feel
like people love aqua
that's eventually what mostly is seems
to have become the case and I'm very
grateful for that yeah that's that's
kind of amazing so I guess as a red dead
fan yeah that that you were afraid that
people were gonna reject this new
protagonist because it wasn't wasn't
John yeah
it wouldn't have been a second one had
it not been for the quality of the first
one you know so obviously there was a
lot of things that I was I wanted to
live up to yeah but as long as we do
just as well as the first one I'll be
happy so it wasn't a struggle to keep
track of the character no I had a pretty
good knowledge even though we were get
we didn't shoot it chronologically yeah
but I I I was pretty good at mentally
putting the pieces of the jigsaw
together
uh what was difficult would be sometimes
return I mean we would start a scene and
then we might not finish it for until
three years later that's so wild and
that was when the animators were
invaluable because I'd be like what the
hell did they would show us what we did
for three years ago and that would
refresh our memories and then one of my
things I was paranoid about would be
like I wanted to keep the accent
consistent yeah for such a long period
of time you just want to make sure
you're doing the same thing as you were
three years ago so they helped me with
that as well did you do
um I don't remember what the word is
like did you have someone help with the
with the accent or was that just
something no no I had they I mean if I
asked can you play me a bit from two
years ago they would totally do that
yeah but I remember when I was
auditioning for it I was doing theater
at the time and with a fella from
Flagstaff Arizona helped me out oh cool
but Arthur eventually became some sort
of amalgamation of like Texas and
Southern he's just seven
so you didn't have training beforehand
to to nail that accent down no I worked
on accidents a lot you know and there's
this great website called idea which
stands for international dialects of of
English archive
and it's really handy because you can
find out every dialect from every region
that speaks in the world that speaks
English different ages different genders
you know and they all it's very very
informative So I listened to that and I
worked a bit on that and they did have
some dialect people for
like Haiti I'm not Haiti guarma that
chapter and when you're in the yeah that
was kind of based on a Dr kind of Haiti
vibe they had they had a dialect coach
for the Italians wanted to make sure
that they sounded authentically Italian
you know but uh no not for me I guess I
was I guess the test it's naturally good
at it the Brits bought it Alana dude the
first time that I realized that you want
Southern I was like what the [__] not
even American Idol I was like I think it
might have even been at the game awards
you know that that was the first time
that I had heard you speak as you and I
was like holy [__] like it's just
completely shatters everything I knew
it's like when Hugh Laurie showed up for
house yeah well that take that is a huge
compliment thank you yeah thank you so
much do you think that that's an
important part of your job that's not
something I've spoken anyone about on
this show before I mean your accent I
don't know if it's one that gets casted
as much like your natural accent do you
feel like you needing to know
International accents is a huge thing I
almost never did work in my normal voice
everything because I was all over the
shop as a kid you know if believe it or
not when I'm in Ireland they they think
I'm American and you know I'm in the and
then I I lived in the UK for a decade as
well so it's I I'm able to do a lot of
those Regional accents pretty well at
least to a native standard you know so
that's I think that's what started me
off uh with the voice acting career more
so than a lot of my theater experience
but I'm really grateful for my
theatrical experience because I think
that really helped me do the performance
capture you know yeah uh because you
gotta have a lot of suspension of
disbelief you've gotta You've Gotta Have
a good imagination when you're doing
pcap because here we are trying to be
tough Cowboys and spandex yeah spandex
with the balls and the dots and
everything yeah yeah I love it I love it
yeah do you feel like um
the approach that you have to acting in
pcap performance capture or acting on
stage are they vastly different like do
you have to move differently what are
some of the major differences between
those two very physical kinds of acting
oh that's a good question so uh it
depends like you know pcap for gaming is
slightly different for performance
capture for Cinema you know we're going
to see that a lot when Avatar 2 comes
out next month yeah but uh you know
typically in gaming you know when you're
doing pcap it's usually an in-game it's
we I did all the animations so except
for major stunts so even the in-game
animations is me too
wow
all of it was me I mean me and Rob
wiedoff shared the side missions we
would because it could be because
depending when you play and it could be
either or so we shared doing the side
missions he might do the mocap for one
then I would AGR to his motion
afterwards oh that's interesting
yeah but uh to go back to what I was
saying I
it's all in the details for me and
that's why I was so grateful for the
animators when they would show me the
environment of wherever we were so I'd
go okay if we're in the swamp I remember
to swat for the odd fly that wasn't
there or if we were up in the mountains
I'd remember to
to be chilly you know and uh and and all
that add those little tiny things in for
authenticity
but I'm really grateful for my
theatrical experience as well because
the audience is right there you learn in
real time what doesn't doesn't work like
if you work on film you're you know
you're you your performance might not be
on the receiving end of an audience for
a year 18 months afterwards and by then
it's too late but if you're doing the
same show every night on stage you over
a time you start to learn
what doesn't doesn't work and and then
that that helps with everything else
that every other medium that you're
performing you know I felt that maybe it
did for for gaming as well yeah do you
feel like the physicality of them is is
super different
so if it's a cut scene it's more
cinematic if it's in game then you've
got you've got to remember it's probably
a much wider shot the player is looking
at your back so then you can afford to
be a bit more theatrical and you want to
be a little bit bigger that's a lot to
think about Yeah well yeah I guess but
and now these days they
the editing is so good they can
seamlessly blend in from in-game to cut
scenes and vice versa but uh that was
one of the things I always wanted to
know and you usually could tell by the
script but sometimes you couldn't is
this in-game or is this a gonna be a cut
scene and if it is a cut scene what kind
of camera angle are you thinking
but they could change their mind and
post if they wanted to well but that's
true and there's a lot of cameras you
can make anything they want work really
you can move it put it wherever you want
yep do you have that's one of the things
that blows my mind about God of War
because they stuck with the one track
the one Earth the whole game's the one
it's so hard Roger it's so hard you have
no idea how hot it is I can I can I've
been thinking about it and no I'm sure I
can't but I can appreciate how hard it
is but it looks it's it works it's so
good yeah and it really helps with the
immersion yeah there were periods of God
of War 2018 where people were like it's
not gonna work it's we have to drop it
it's not going to work but Corey was
just so stubborn about keeping it and I
think it it I agree it really helps with
immersion you just feel like you're
always in it and yeah it's it's very
impressive and very challenging so I'm
glad you liked it before the show
started uh Roger was just telling me
that he just finished Ragnarok just
finished it today oh yeah
is that how you spend your Thanksgiving
well no I was cooking I was cooking for
13 people yesterday oh wow
nice all right I was playing I caught up
I finished Ragnarok today very good yeah
glad you liked it
um so do you have a favorite kind of
acting like is there something that if I
were to to tell you you got to do this
tomorrow is it performance capture is it
theater is it film and and how different
do you feel like they are
well I feel most experienced now in in
theater and performance capture and I
love both and but honestly I just love
to work and I love new challenges
uh I have been I've got a few projects
in the gaming industry now coming up and
that's been a real joy and another real
cool thing is to see the technology
advanced in front of your very eyes you
know even sometimes when you're working
on the same project and you go oh my God
they can do that now yeah for example a
lot of the in-game animations that it
some of those took weeks and weeks to do
with red dead and now I'm working on
games where they can get it done in half
a day
you know and it and it and if they need
less data from the in the volume to be
able to translate it into what they need
for in-game it just blows my mind it's
one of the coolest things about working
in video games is that it's no it's
still in its infancy we're still just
evolving every day all the time it's
it's very very cool to watch yeah I
think AI is going to bring some really
cool things to the NPC world and true
yeah yeah yeah not having to do all that
stuff by hand it takes a long time and
the faster we can get and the more
memory we can get the cooler games are
gonna get it's just it's definitely very
exciting
um so you have a preference for for
anything physical and I'd love to ask
like what goes into when you're trying
to come up with the physicality of the
character any character though I guess
author's the easiest one for me to
reference
how much are you thinking about like
what he's going to be wearing at the
time even if you're in a mocap suit is
it do you have your head on like well
I'll have cowboy boots on I'd have a
belt here like is that stuff that you
just consciously think about all the
time
yes yeah and also where where is their
center of gravity how do they walk you
know and how do they and what mood are
they in and which particular part of
scene and how does that affect the way
that they walk and typically I try not
to prepare the same way every time I
have a different role I try to prepare
for it in a different way because I
think if I just keep doing the same
thing I'll just keep coming up with the
same thing
so there's some things I've used in the
past was to like use animal work you
know and to try and
try and take inspiration from from
certain members of the animal kingdom
and what have you and and then um and
obviously with with regards to red dead
anyway I knew that Arthur's walk was
going to be something that was going to
be looked at quite a bit yeah
so yeah that was something that I was
conscious of walking in absolutely you
know and uh so what is the research that
you do like is that like a notebook is
it like you mentioned it before that
you'd watch movies
and I was playing a lot of games and uh
and you know anti-circus is a huge
inspiration too because of what he's
done with mocap and uh I was always
trying to get whatever behind the scenes
footage I could of Lord of the Rings and
Planet of the Apes and other video games
as well uh you know I mean I know Nolan
did it after Red Dead came out but when
he was doing that playthrough of the
Uncharted series I loved it because you
got to hear all those behind the scenes
stories and be like Oh yeah I remember
this day and I lived for that and I
could relate uh but uh and also you you
know some if you're not well versed in
performance capture as an actor you
sometimes you don't know what the limit
the technological limitations are and
you learn pretty fast that the animators
just as valuable as the Director and
oftentimes they work side by side in
tandem with each other because the
animator is is they're the ones who can
tell you what you can and can't do yeah
I remember so many times we you know
we'd come up with a scene we'd be
working at it and working at it
and eventually the director would be
like oh thank God that's brilliant take
that and then the animator would step in
and go no sorry if you can use that
because this foot was two inches
what are you crazy there's also a lot of
stuff to do with uh with clothing like I
think in The Last of Us Part Two
Ellie I think maybe takes her shirt off
and it took somebody months and months
and months and months to animate that
like if you move your clothing in a
certain way it becomes a nightmare um
because the straps of the gun over the
shoulders
uh I can totally understand that I think
initially with jolly used to put his
hand in his pocket a lot and the
animators had to be like that's so
[__] hard can you please stop putting
your hand in your pocket
um can you stop folding your arms yeah
and you know and at a certain point you
have to go well that would be that's a
very human thing that would happen now
you know I used to I would put my hands
on my belt buckle that I imagined to be
there yeah and the anime is like how'd
you know there's a boat Buckle there and
I'm like well come on he's a cowboy
so it's some of the things that I did
would help lend to inform their work and
vice versa and as the years went by we
got to understand each other's work more
and more so we became a pretty solid
team you know but after a while I
started to understand why the foot had
to be two inches to the left because at
the beginning I'd be like what
difference did mistake two watches yeah
but then you know then it helps it helps
with the immersiveness if you can just
seamlessly blend into a cut scene
without you don't even sometimes I don't
even know it's a cutscene yeah that's
that's something that I really admire
when I'm playing games now and that
happened a lot of in Ragnarok too you
know I think the recent uh Tomb Raider
games are really good at that too I
often don't know when I'm in a cutscene
or cinematic when they start and I'll
still be holding the controller because
I think I'm the thing and I'm like oh
this is a cutscene it's super super
impressive yeah it is it's definitely a
lot of learning I guess and I suppose
like when you work on a game for that
long with with by Shima similar team you
probably just have to be very
collaborative and become a tight unit
and I guess yeah you do have to
sometimes make a case against the
animators where you'd be like well but
he would be following his arms here and
that's yeah
yeah like I created a lot of extra work
for them because there'd be some moments
where I'd be like well he would take his
hat off to a lady yeah we don't know if
he's wearing a hat or not all right well
then let's do two versions then it makes
sense
yeah because you can lose the Hat you
can lose the Hat you got to keep it in
mind yeah but another thing another
difference too is at least when you're
the protagonist anyways it's like if
you're working on film or something you
know you gotta
if you're the lead and if you're the the
protagonist you know you gotta you need
to get the audience on your side you
know and hopefully you need to do that
as soon as possible for the sake of a
narrative but in gaming if you're the
protagonist or the playable character
you know a lot of that work is already
done for you because the player
identifies as used they're already on
your side you know it's a really good
point yeah but the real challenge is and
we're seeing this more and more as
storytelling gets more and more
sophisticated is they'll be they'll
possibly be multiple endings which is
influenced by the player's Behavior so
when you get to like the the latter half
of the story
you've got to come up with obviously
they might have different scenes for the
same part of the story you know and
for major major plot points that will
always be the case but sometimes for
lesser plot points it'll be the same
size
and then you got to come up with a
performance that's ambiguous enough to
suit whether they're a bastard or of
high honor or a low honor or whether
they're doing this branch of the
narrative or the other branch of the
narrative you've got to come up with a
performance that fits both yeah but
still loyal to the character that the
player has been getting used to this
whole time yeah and I guess with red
dead it's morality too like you can kind
of play author as a dick so I was
morality that was my binary thing was
whether he's a good guy or a low honor
guy but with other stories like Mass
Effect for example is different this
yeah and that that juggling that in your
head that was a bit of a challenge it's
also very hard to write I don't think
I'm allowed to say what game it was for
yet but I wrote um branching narrative
for a game and writing those scenes
where like you know you have to write
for players to have a choice of what to
say but you have to make sure that every
single option makes sense with every
other option so that you don't have like
a um
what was it LA Noire where someone is
just suddenly very mad like the previous
sentence they were like interesting and
then they're like no you killed someone
and it's like makes the characters are
really weird it's really hard to do and
what I was doing to try to get through
that was just repeatedly read through
every single option out loud because
otherwise it's not easy no you just make
people sound crazy you got it it's
mathematical almost yeah
it's very technical a lot of a lot of
Arts in uh where video games are
concerned I think is very technical at
least like I would think less so than
theater I look at theaters as a more of
a generic performance art generic not
the right word but it's just like more
art I don't know it's not the video
games aren't but they're so Technical
and you have to think so technically all
the time that it's not like it's not as
romantic as I think maybe people expect
it to be when you have to just Factor
all those things in did you have Choose
Your Own Adventure books when you were
kids yep yeah that's what it reminds me
of totally write a lot of Goosebumps
although it's it's a lot more it's a lot
more complicated though it's still kind
of where it came from though yeah and I
loved that because that empowered me
yeah as a kid that I found that very
empowering yeah I love those they're
awesome yeah I tried to write one once
it's too hard like the amount of uh it's
like mapping the pages is hard being
like okay wait man this goes to what
page like it's super I don't even know
how people write those but I used to
read the Goosebumps ones the scary ones
they were awesome and then you'd be like
oh I died okay go back to it no I didn't
like you just reload page yeah it's that
that is totally a Big inspiration for
for modern video gaming like no doubt
um so to take us very off track here uh
how did you actually start out what was
the beginning of your career as an actor
did you always know that you wanted to
be one and and where did it start
I was involved with amateur Dramatics
when I was a kid and uh it's something
that I always enjoyed but you know when
I was a teenager I didn't really have
I I wasn't brave enough to think of even
think of pursuing it as a career I
didn't think you know because I knew how
fickle the industry was and how tough it
was so I I started out in computers
which I was really bad at and I
eventually bit the bullet and figured to
myself you know you'll be like
engineering
I did I I did a what were you calling
the states an associate's degree in
computer studies oh no way yeah cool and
then I I sucked at it so and then I
transferred to a ba in theater
and uh it was hard at first you know it
was hard but first 10 years of my career
you know I was struggling but I I got I
was working and uh and I'm very grateful
for the experiences that I had
especially starting out you know theater
was it really taught me everything do
you started uh theater acting in the UK
yeah were you working for like one of
those Productions or or um theater
companies where you got paid absolutely
nothing yeah because I feel like that's
pretty common there is like you get paid
like a pound like just nothing my first
job was what they call these tie
contracts uh theater and education where
you'd go around and just do Shakespeare
to kids at nine o'clock in the morning
you know and they don't want to be there
that was that was wonderful kids are a
very honest audience it's true you suck
yeah what what ages are you doing that
to
oh this would have been around
adolescent kids I remember so we would
do like bite-sized Shakespeare so bits
and Bobs from different plays and it
would last like half an hour to 10 to 12
year olds
and those sometimes so it was insane I
remember one kid getting it was a fight
broke out and he's throwing another kid
up on the stage and everything and wow
and the teachers the teachers love it
because they're finally like oh finally
a bit of a break
they're not doing anything oh God from
the Shakespeare man yeah harsh way to
start but it seems like that's common in
the UK is that you started absolute
pennies and just working where you can
I've heard stories of people great way
to start you gotta pay your dues yeah
yeah I've heard people saying that they
were paid less money than it costed them
to get to their job as actors starting
out in the UK yeah that's why that can
happen yeah that can happen so then
where do you go from there and then we
started doing proper theaters then from
that
and then around the same time uh I
eventually moved to London because that
was where most of the work yeah of
course I trained in Wales and Cardiff
and if you speak Welsh you can do pretty
well as an actor in Wales but I did not
speak well so London was the next stop
and uh I started bookmore theater there
uh proper theater and a bit of film and
TV work as well and that's when I got
into voice over and I would do the
accents that I was comfortable with so I
would do American and Irish
but I didn't get hired too much as a
Brit in Britain because for some reason
they didn't you know they knew where I
was from so they bought it but as soon
as I moved back to the States I my
pigeonhole increased by a whole third
then because then I could finally get
away with doing the Brit you know
and I moved to New York and start and
then carried on just doing what I did
there and uh make you know just you just
never give I never gave up
you probably should have a few times but
I'm glad I didn't now looking back on it
yeah
um what was your first video game
I did I I think it was The Witcher I did
a bit of voice on The Witcher the first
one and that was mostly cast out of
London oh yeah and then I did what was
my first ever voice over gigs was for a
slot machine yeah so I guess it was
called Reservoir frogs excellent yeah
they're very good they needed a Michael
Madsen sound alike oh my God so I just
went on it it was a couple hours and I
was mostly just me just rhyming off
fruit so I go cherries bananas oh my God
lemons
I remember I remember the cover art it
was a frog holding a human ear Reservoir
frogs Yeah and that was a what they well
they I say slot machine because that's
what the Yanks understand but the Brits
Norma's fruit machines fruit machines
really yeah and they're in every bar we
have them in a lot of bars uh in
Australia too yeah
no wow Reservoir frogs I found it is it
there yeah holy cow yeah I haven't
looked that up for eight that's so funny
wow
that was my first game I guess you could
say it counts yeah
um
so I imagine that's a weird introduction
to video games and wasn't necessarily
one that was gonna make you be like I
want to pursue this this is a path
um did you ever failed to get a job for
sure right right you just you're just
happy to have work at that point
um did you ever have aspirations to be a
video game protagonist so when you were
starting out acting was your attitude
just I just want work there was no like
goal that you had in mind no I just
wanted to be challenged but I never
anticipated it or get I would slip into
gaming somehow I never thought that
would happen you thought it would stay
theater or yeah I was doing pretty well
with the theater company out of Germany
we I worked for them for over a decade
we went all around the world and that
was where I was in Australia with that
company and we there was always work for
those guys yeah and it was hard to make
a living but you could you know you
could just about do it I wouldn't be
able to do it now but back then I could
yeah and you know you live it's like the
Rock and Roll Lifestyle they're living
out of a suitcase in a different Hotel
every night different theater every
night except not the money or or you
know this but apart from that it was
very rock and roll
that kind of travel it's fun but you're
right not the money all the fame
that's a nice uh case lifestyle yeah um
I mean that sounds awesome it's like you
got to tour the world it's uh I got to
go to Australia nobody has to do that
um if you were to give yourself advice
from when you were just starting out
what do you think that you would say
like when you were just beginning oh wow
yeah don't take don't take all the
rejection personally
especially when it is personal because
sometimes it is you know and but most of
the time it's something that you you
have no control over you know I don't
know if what's the one thing about this
industry is it's so fickle and talent is
no guarantee and you know there's so
many talented actors out there who don't
get the same opportunities as others and
it's really just it's just like throwing
throwing a ball up in the air and
I don't know if I would wish that on
anyone uh but it's what I ended up doing
and once I was invested in it I was
invested in it so I I would tell myself
not to give up and
just to remember that
something will come eventually every no
brings you closer to your next yes it is
I think it's a big it's a big sales
pitch no but it's true it's I was just
talking to
um Danielle about this he was on the
last episode about the amount of
rejection that I feel like actors have
to face I don't think most people could
deal with and I think it's more than
most people think like the fact that you
have to study asides
get to know a character fleetingly
submit a tape or see people in person
and then they just never contact you
again you've used your profession to
create something for them and then they
just ghost you it wasn't good enough
sorry but no it oftentimes you have to
remind yourself you know you don't know
what they want you might not be tall
enough yeah that's sometimes it's
usually something completely out of your
control which makes it a little easier
but since covid
you know there's more hardly any
auditions in person anymore so we're all
doing stuff on tape and we don't get the
same feedback as we used to I miss that
yeah I missed that chatting to a casting
director who's chatted to the producer
or the director who actually as
firsthand information of what it is that
they're looking for we since covid we
don't really get that anymore
yeah much more of a shot in the dark but
they want Advantage is if you're not
happy with it you can just do it again
but it's much more of a shot in the dark
now do you have any advice for people
trying to submit auditions or like
anything that you try to stand by like I
know one thing that um
that at least Santa Monica Studio has
looked for is just people making a
choice just really committing to yeah
doing something with the character even
if it's wrong even it's the wrong choice
at least show that you've done some work
yeah absolutely so true yeah and it's so
much easier to turn something turn it
down than to turn it up you know so if
you do make a choice commit to it and
make it clear and obvious you know
because it's much easier to pull it back
than to turn it up again because they
might not think you can turn it up true
uh
but my gosh you know what else I've
started to learn too is I've realized
the breakdowns are more for the agent
than the actor
you know the breakdowns is more of a
clue so that the agent knows okay well
this client fits that that client fits
that but the actors shouldn't pay so
much attention to it because if they pay
too much attention to it then
everybody's going to be sending in the
same audition good point you've got to
add a bit of your own personal stamp to
whatever the sides are you know you've
got to make it unique as well as make
your own choices clear but you've got to
make it yours as well because if there's
nothing else that will help you stand
out from the rest
you're absolutely right if they all
sound the same then it's just going to
be down to I don't know this guy kind of
looks right like it's it's gonna be not
even based on acting really if you also
submit the same thing it's a really good
thing and this one's based in La so we
don't need to fly them in or you know I
mean I mean some it comes down to that
right yeah that's true yeah very good
point um do you have any advice for
people who might want to get into acting
um or people who are just starting out
don't
um
no um you know just realize that uh
that uh it's not I think there will
there will be there will be difficulties
you know and uh
and if you but if you throw enough [__]
on the wall something will stick
eventually yeah definitely I don't give
up because it's just such a competitive
industry and work begets work even if
it's something that you might not have
initially attract your attention you
know it's any opportunity to show your
wares to someone who hasn't seen them
before should be taken hmm
I could say that for people who started
out and focus on theater too because
theater
that you learn in real time you know
you they are you never hear half of the
room laugh you know you never hear half
of the room boo they all the audience is
like one entity usually and when you
learn how to feed them and when you
learn how to listen to your audience as
well as they're listening to you that's
when some some magic can start to happen
and you can take that with you to other
mediums like film and whatnot except now
instead of an audience you just got to
imagine your audience is that tiny
little
hole on the lens you know and then hyper
Focus your performance to that audience
member but when you learn when you learn
how to uh how to cater and it helps you
with timing too you know because you're
doing the same material every night yeah
so often you'll get a laugh one night
and then the next night you won't get a
laugh at all even though you've tried
twice as hard for it and oftentimes the
reason why you didn't get a laugh is
because you tried twice as hard for it
so you learn how to how to make it
appear natural every time and and you
learn not to spoon feed your audience
and to let them figure some stuff out
themselves because that's what audiences
like to do you know they like to use
their brains I guess the tip there is in
part try to fail a little so that at
least you learn from it yeah
more productive than just succeeding all
the time and not taking any risks you
probably won't go anywhere and you won't
learn anything
happy accidents are sometimes the best
teachers yeah oh my god I didn't even
think of that yeah yeah so when it comes
to Authority more specifically
um so you got that role you were working
on that for five years which is such a
long time and you said you were you were
nervous
about taking over from from John how did
you feel when the game came out and
everybody finally met Arthur what was
that experience like
well it's very encouraging everybody
seemed to uh have a it was mostly a
positive response which I was very
grateful for I was just aiming that we
would wouldn't disappoint the fans of
the franchise I don't think we did that
okay I'm very very thrilled did you
watch a lot of like let's plays or
streams or any of that kind of stuff no
I didn't I I have maybe over covet I did
yeah there's a whole montage of just
people bawling their eyes out yeah
spoilers which I did not expect at all
the even Markiplier's had a little bit
of a tear in his eye from one of the
things yeah
and then that game that I will never
stands out to me so much is
um you're riding back to
the camp the one that's like by the
river and I was so sure that I was
riding Arthur to his death because you
know he does because he has to and so
there's this really interesting thing
that Red Dead 2 manages to do that I
don't know of many other games that do
where if you know that the character is
going to die because it's a prequel he's
not there anymore I felt so responsible
for him all the time that I was like if
I finish this ride is Arthur gonna die
and then and then he starts coughing and
you're like no what's happening then I
feel like I have to know what happens
next yeah and you don't want to stop but
there is a welder I was like if I just
stop playing Arthur can live forever
maybe I just leave him alone and then he
doesn't have to die and it's it's very
very impactful in a way that I don't
think a lot of games have you been
attempted to to do that's one of the
things I was grateful for because uh you
know it was very similar to the first
Red Dead Redemption and that you you're
the anti the pa the person you played
meets their demise half you know before
the game is finished but I loved the way
that they'd made it different from John
because if John is this short sharp
shock that you're not expecting and with
Arthur it's the Slow Burn and when is it
going to happen yeah and what does this
life mean and it makes him question his
whole life and it changes his whole
approach and indeed in some ways the
players approach too
to uh to what we're doing and how much
and how you spend your time and who you
spend it helping is yeah I just feel
like it's such a powerful thing of like
feeling responsible for being alive so
just yeah loads of dynamite and sandony
yeah people is it possible yeah yeah
yeah it's it's those are the those are
the teenage boys usually
it's just something it's kind of fun so
every once in a while you can find a
little Alleyway a narrow Alleyway and
send a knee make a mountain of cops it's
a lot of fun too
and then if you if you if you get your
honor down too low you just say hello to
everyone for about 20 minutes and that
brings it right back up what a nice guy
wave the KKK got me when you see the KKK
in that game yeah and you don't get you
don't get punished no and then the
Eugenics guy in San Diego too oh yeah I
forgot about it doesn't drop yeah oh the
the KKK thing was like one of the only
times in those games like even in GTA
I'm a person who will like mostly try
not to run of pedestrians
um and I was like tying them by the leg
and trying to feed them to alligators
and [__] like I was like oh really don't
if you don't do anything and if you just
leave him alone and just watch them for
ages one of the cut scenes they end up
lighting themselves on fire oh do they
really I didn't know that no way that's
great yeah oh that's awesome yeah I mean
I just feel like it must have been um a
very from my perspective it must have
been a very welcoming experience
becoming Arthur Morgan and having you
know uh everybody just fall in love with
him so it was an honor and a blessing it
really was an honor and a blessing to be
involved in a project like that because
everyone I mean Rockstar top shelf in my
opinion and so are Santa Monica too
obviously I reckon I think there's the
Blessed Trinity of video games there's
Naughty Dog Santa Monica and Rockstar
performance is concerned you know yeah
and I love I I just it was a pleasure
you know because everyone's so
intelligent and everyone's so talented
and there's no weak link and you know
everyone has the common goal and it was
it was just a real joy to be part of
something like that and then for it to
be received in a positive way like it
has been that's just every actor's dream
come true to be to have an audience an
appreciative audience of that size
totally because I'm I keep pinching
myself were you nervous at all like
before release day waiting to oh yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely they're like
Arthur Who
[Laughter]
oh I can't even imagine it is it is a I
hadn't thought about it in that way that
there's a big Shadow to live up to and
the fact that you had played the game
and had that context just must have uh
done something to your brain for sure I
was playing all the Rockstar Games while
I was making it oh nice yeah so yeah I
was like okay no pressure did you read
all the reviews like were you paying
attention to the review embargo a little
bit a little bit yeah and some of it was
almost it was pretty amazing although
one guy did complain because he wasn't
allowed to call his horse [__] Factory
and to that guy all I can do is
sincerely apologize that's not fair yeah
you should apologize can you write write
the apology down please put it on
Twitter oh I I forgotten how to get in
contact with him but who knows how long
Twitter's Gonna Last Alana right I know
you got to get that apology out stat I'm
gonna look up [__] Factory so sorry you
couldn't call him [__] Factory yeah you
can't you can't name your horse any
naughty words
seem odd
[__] Factory I'm trying to see if I can
find it on Google if it comes up but it
might not oh there's a tweet about you
talking about it that's funny oh really
yeah okay there are a few results for
[__] factories so people have spoken
about you saying that
that's so funny
maybe you can do it online maybe you can
name maybe you can use profanity online
who knows oh surely I mean I was trying
to call um I've been playing the latest
Pokemon game and I wanted to call my
main Pokemon [__] uh Pokemon would
have let me but you look at him he's
such a [__] he just looks like a
dummy and I was like wow no [__] got
it devastating definitely state for you
exactly when will it end the censorship
of Nintendo come on
yeah I don't know I just can't I mean
having just you know worked on Ragnarok
and seeing the reviews and everything it
was definitely a little bit overwhelming
being really well received and well done
on the accessibility too Alana because I
I know honestly I have heard a lot of
people really really highly praising
that aspect of it and I know that it is
very good yeah Sony's been really good
at that lately and I haven't accessed
all the I looked at the menu and I was
like holy cow you you yeah you just you
you're taking it up you've taken it up a
notch yeah the the team is incredible um
run by Mila who is wonderful
um and they really care there were so
many things when working on the
accessibility stuff that I'd be like hey
can we do this and someone would say
well we'll try and if we can't do it for
this game we'll do it for the next game
every time it was always like there was
never a no there was never it's been
expensive it was it just wasn't an
option to say no it was always we will
always do the most that we can and it's
really important in studio and it yeah
it's I do think Sony's really good at it
actually like the Last of Us Part One
um it's probably the most successful
game ever made and it is very good yeah
I would think so I mean it's it's well I
haven't played the Remake have they uh I
gotta check that out I think that might
be next I I want to check out Modern
Warfare 2. I haven't played a Call of
Duty game in so long but Modern Warfare
2 looks really cool do you play
multiplayer games
I'm too bad I don't have the time I
can't compete with these 11 year olds
qualities four hours a day they're so
good so fast I can't do Call of Duty I
could do Battlefield Call of Duty is too
fast and they're all angry and then they
tell you to do things to your mother I
know what's that they did something to
your mother what what is my mom up to
dear God my mom is not no it's me it's
my fault I'm [__] you know but I'm doing
this to my own mother
um yeah because I didn't realize that
you played games so much but what's your
what's your favorite game
Red Dead too no that's cheating come on
I I was a big gamer and I I play it
occasionally now
um
um recently I really enjoyed ghost
tsushima last of us too I really enjoyed
the Final Fantasy VII remake especially
the music like they got a full-blown
square Square Enix got this full-blown
yeah Orchestra this time I remember
playing it originally it was all poly it
was just the monophonic but now with the
full-blown orchestra that blew my mind
and uh I grew up on
Street Fighter to I I was like I'm the
first generation that grew up on video
games so I had an Atari and then a
Nintendo and then a Super Nintendo and
then a PlayStation and I
Final Fantasy Resident Evil 2 Street
Fighter 2. oh yeah
uh all that stuff good video games you
still play Resident Evil
uh no I haven't in a while now they're
really good these days the the remixes
that's insane well you're also currently
working on a horror game or at least did
just work on horror game it's not out
yet yeah I mean enjoy it yeah we're
putting the finishing touches up they
apparently will be out next year but you
never know how how is that experience
working on something that's that's
Horror oh it was a brilliant thing this
is a set on Mars so it's no no Western
at all but you know working with Troy
was one of the best in the business that
was the real pleasure and I've gotten to
known him as a colleague and a friend
now which was wonderful uh but working
with him was really cool and seeing how
the technology like earlier like it had
been a while since I had been in a
volume so seeing how the technology had
gotten better and
I'm really excited to show the gaming
audiences a different side of me as
opposed to just Arthur because this
fella is not Arthur that's about it he
seems very different to Arthur what's
the character's name I don't remember
are you allowed to exactly there you go
that's it yeah Jack Leary yeah what what
accent are you doing he's Irish he is
Irish that must feel nice too I thought
he was one of the few things I've done
in my own act in my own voice that's
awesome yeah but when you're approaching
something that has jump scares when it
comes to mocap how does that work I
guess the character isn't usually
jumping
it's typically more in game because you
know it's obviously the it's it's
something that the player needs to do to
to preempt to you know to to spawn so uh
you know that's typically in game but I
would have to do the reactions yeah and
and how does that work how do you
approach
doing horror I don't I have no idea
never asked anyone the question before
how does horror mocap work
well you know it's all it's it's a lot
like comedy it's all about the timing
yeah uh and but then it's hard because
sometimes you're not you know you're not
in control of the timing because
sometimes the player might hang around
and not do what they're supposed to do
so you have to try and find a way to
keep the tension up even though you
might not have control over the timing
that's the that's the challenge you know
yeah but uh you know we people are
getting better better at kind of nudging
the the player in the right direction
yeah
uh like hurting them almost like they
were like The Sheepdogs of of of the PS5
and the Xbox world you know there are a
lot of tricks for that like like just
yeah even lines like in the hallway it
looks like it it points this way then
people just are drawn to it
automatically kind of go that direction
yeah absolutely and then you'll have a
little red herring and then the real
scares immediately after yeah is that
stuff all on the page like this is that
all in the script
typically no interesting uh sometimes it
is sometimes it isn't you know
um but you've got to perform it yeah
yeah it must be a weird one I just I
don't know I guess that's that's why you
are where you are and I am not it's like
I can't imagine being scared of
something that is probably a lot of the
time not even there because it's not
well then I that but then that's where
my gaming helps me out I think oh is
this like that bit an alien what was it
Resurrection right
is that which one is it called isolation
probably Resurrection also exists but
you're almost definitely thinking of
isolation isolation is the good one for
like almost 10 years ago yeah is it 10
years old it might be it must be right
in isolation it was the um
and the thing is you don't you don't see
the alien until like well over a third
of the way in the game when that's the
way to do it too you know you gotta
build it all you gotta build that so I
actually and I tell people this all the
time
um I saw the alien before anyone knew
you could
yeah that alien killed me
far sooner in that game than I had seen
anyone else die anywhere on the internet
at the time I'm sure more people have
done it now but when the game came out I
played it in 2014 and I recorded it the
first time the alien kills me is right
before you first get on the tram station
which is maybe two hours in I had never
seen that happen to anyone else and I
think that's a credit to how cool that
game is it's the way that alien AI Works
maybe you found a shortcut to death
maybe you're it was just you I died real
early like way before yeah it took me
ages yeah because I think it's always
there it's just not always necessarily
going to attack so
yeah that I mean that game is fantastic
and you're right that being a gamer
probably does help and and adds uh
assist your imagination at the very
least
I can imagine it'd be very difficult if
you don't have that also for the record
everybody uh the game we're talking
about is Fort solace uh yes because we
didn't say the name I didn't say the
name you and Troy are in and I'm very
very excited to play it I know some of
the um at summer game Fest was where you
guys spoke about it we introduced it
with uh Jeff's thing summer game Fest
we're very excited to show it to you all
Fort Solace Solace spelled s-o-l-i-s you
can check out the trailer on YouTube
right now it's I think it's gonna come
out next year it's going to be on PC and
Playstation very excited that those are
confirmed we're waiting on other stuff
yeah I know Troy explained it is um I
think while he was there
he just commented on it being like
constantly thrilling he was like he
would describe it more as a thriller
than a horror and and said it just had a
lot of tension all the time and he
seemed to be very enthusiastic about
that so you might need some new
underwear hmm is it weird that that
excites me for video games scare the
[__] out of me let's go I want to do it
I love it so much
um so for for all of the games you have
worked on like are they vastly done a
lot to be fair compared to Troy my gosh
I'm a rookie but that's too many who
needs to work on that mini cut all right
Troy come on now you know it's pipe down
a little bit all right calm down uh
there's a reason he keeps yeah he's
incredible and it's it's interesting
it's I think it's very nice that every
actor that I ever talked to who works
with Troy is always like I got to work
with Troy and everyone like who seems to
love working with him and he does
directing now too and
um supposedly people think he's a
fantastic director of actors because he
has the experience of being an actor so
Troy is great at what he does but for
the difference of recording something
like Fort Solace and
recording uh Red Dead
would you say they are
so different that it is almost like
recording a western movie and then
recording a horror movie or because of
the volume and because of the cameras in
the mocap suit they're not that
different is your approach as different
as we picture it being no it was very
different because the team is different
the technology had Advanced yeah and uh
and it is a completely different genre
as you point out yeah so it was it was
an entirely different approach so I
guess there's not it's not just like all
video game acting fits into a blanket it
is still extremely different depending
on the context of the game and I had to
change my walk too because I obviously
for obvious reasons I didn't want people
to go oh it's Arthur but at the same
time you know I'm wearing a totally
different outfit I'm wearing a spacesuit
in this one so you know the the movement
is a little bit more labored uh you know
and it's on we were trying to
incorporate some aspects of the Martian
gravity and what have you and the storms
and so yeah it was a very very different
way to and that's what I love about it
because the performance capture can has
the capacity for all of that different
types of freedom you know you you really
really the whole scope of performance
capture and it's only getting better and
better you can literally do anything
yeah the limits your imagination
did you happen to talk to Troy about the
love death and robots episode that he
did
yes I watched it and I told him he was
awesome at it that was the one on the
pirate ship right yeah and he is so good
but that we had an episode where we
spoke to him about it if play watch
listen where he was talking about the
like giant crab thing yeah how it was
animated it's not so well done so and
it's typical in typical Troy fashion I
was like halfway through it before I
started to go hang on is that Troy I
know I knew he was in the season and I
was like I think this is the Troy one
that that might be Troy but then there's
also like so many games that I play
where Troy's voice shows up and I get
mad and like I again I can't [__]
escape this guy like he's doing
everything it's so funny like a bad
Penny yeah except a very good one
that was that other great one on love
death and robots where it was kind of in
the the jungle and and there was this
this siren who had kept coming in and
out of the water I haven't seen she's
done up all like Indian with Indian
makeup and stuff that was that was done
because I'm not sure Troy's episode was
mocap was it I think was it animated I
think it was mocap I think it was a
combination yeah all right well this
other one was also mocap but it blew my
mind and I started using on real five on
some of that too didn't they or maybe
the most recent season yeah
so for Solace apparently I don't know
don't quote me on this it depends if it
gets delayed further or not but this
might very well be the first video game
that is completely done in the unreal
unreal five engines that's very exciting
I mean it does look gorgeous
it looks incredible yeah I liked what
they did with the storms the Martian
sandstorms they look really cool yeah
yeah I guess that's the thing that when
you're working on it you don't
necessarily know what that looks like
until you eventually see it right you
don't necessarily know what the thing
you're working on actually looks like
depending on what I did a lot of
research on do you know it's not sand
it's rust really all the dust all the
Sands it's rust it's oxide iron oxide
that blows around whoa no and if it's
were to get into your lungs you're I
mean you're done really yeah damn rust
yeah wow good to know does that change
how you approach anything or is it just
a cool fact uh you know it does I don't
know I don't want to give too much away
yeah that's fair enough yeah we don't
want to spoil anything that came soon
still a ways away but very exciting um
so I won't steal too much more of your
time uh last question that I like to ask
people on this show because I think it's
an extra tough one also is that Guinness
no that's not that's too see-through to
be Guinness but it would have been very
own brand it's just a dark beer Cheers
Cheers first one was a Guinness it was
now I've graduated to Sam Adams very
good it's very cliche of you to drink
Guinness to be honest you're a walking
stereotype I am yeah I am
um who is your favorite actor your
favorite actor of all time or your
favorite performance of all time oh
that's really hard to say I can't but
Daniel J Lewis is up there he's very
good yeah I definitely I like Gene
Hackman as well yeah
there's a lot of Australian actresses
that I love yeah I love Kate I think
Kate Blanchett might be my favorite
Naomi Watts is amazing yeah Nicole
Kidman I remember when I when I remember
when I was when my wife was pregnant
with our first child there was a Naomi
Watts article that really helped me
because I was a nervous wreck and I
thought oh my God you know how am I
going to look I wasn't I wasn't I wasn't
doing exceptionally well I was still
bartending you know I was like how am I
gonna do this and
so terrified and you know I read an
article Naomi Watts interview and she
said that she went through something
similar when she was having her first
child but then after the child was born
she said you become more economic in
your choices because we were talking
about choices earlier on and so
oftentimes so often you know an actor
Will double second guess themselves you
know and they're like oh that you know
and often we deny our first impulses
because we don't trust ourselves enough
or we we think oh that might that's
probably not what they're looking for
and Naomi Watts said I decided to start
throwing all that stuff out of the
window because she simply didn't have
the time to second-guess herself so she
would trust her instincts more and that
helped me no end
when I uh when I started having kids
because I still don't book any work I'm
joking I guess then yeah your your job
isn't just for you anymore it's for
literal children and that's definitely
scary with that kind of job and it's
okay if and sometimes it's okay if you
don't have time I mean sometimes your
first impulse is the best impulse and to
trust your trust your instincts fair
enough yeah oh sorry
um any any closing thoughts anything
else that you would like to share Before
I Let You Go
no it's it's uh is that an old school
PlayStation emblem you got on there it
is yeah I love the old one it is nice
I've got a windbreaker like that too
yeah it drives me nuts that PlayStation
was established in 1994 because I'm born
in 1993 and all the merch I'm like just
one year then what have all been
established 93 come on it would have
been so nice but I have crazy just from
the staff store we get crazy discounts
you can get like shirts for like two
dollars so I have a lot of PlayStation
merch and I think Nintendo was like
1890s wasn't it yeah I mean when they
started it was a completely different
kind of company 1890 yeah I'm gonna
guess 97 I had to do this in trivia once
when I say Nintendo
founded God Nintendo has so much money
you know um got a war Ragnarok uh we
sold 5.1 million uh copies in a week
which is crazy and then Nintendo of uh
the latest Pokemon sold I think like 10
million in three days
well let's cross cross platform too I
mean well they've only got two issued
okay for Pokemon but but it's still
people are buying two which is a lot I
would want I would wind Troy up about
that too I'll be like oh yeah yeah it's
pretty good sales Last of Us yeah not as
good as red dead yeah you guys have all
you got all the platforms you got all
the platforms that is Sony that is true
it's totally true
um yeah yeah that's amazing for Ragnarok
that's absolutely that's absolutely
brilliant I was not expecting that
number at all
um so it's nuts but then to get just
absolutely slaughtered by Pokemon which
to be fair Pokemon is the uh highest
grossing franchise of all time bigger
than Mickey Mouse Harry Potter Star Wars
Harry Potter all of it Pokemon wow the
highest grossing franchise of all time
and I don't I hardly know anything about
it I mean you'd know Pikachu and I think
that's enough so like as long as you
know Pikachu we can sell Pikachu that's
all we need it's like just so much money
it's crazy
um but yes Nintendo was founded in 1989
133 years ago in Kyoto oh yeah and what
did they first sell I think it was a
cards paint brushes
yeah that sounds it was it was a card
company yeah it was originally called
Nintendo karuta and they just
distributed flower cards a traditional
type of Japanese playing card
Nintendo is commonly assumed to mean
leave luck to Heaven wow Isn't that cool
I didn't know that yeah Mario
um change the way we say that now we
gotta sound more it's me a Mario
oh he sounds the Mushroom Kingdom Here
We Come here we go here we go it's so
funny my god
um in any case Roger it was very lovely
to talk to you today where can people
find you
also wow my socials so I I am still on
Twitter we'll see how for how much
longer that's at our Clark 98 and I got
Instagram rolling Raj and then I'm on
Tick Tock 2 Roger Clark actor I didn't
know you wanted to talk I'll have to go
check that out yeah I just started doing
it on I mean that seems to be voice
actors is super fun to watch on on Tick
Tock yeah some of them are really good
yeah some of them are hilarious yeah I'm
not so much uh but you know but you're
there I announced things and you know I
try to be amusing I try to be as amusing
as possible we appreciate that I'll
leave a link in the description where
everyone can find you and is there
anything you want to promote that you've
got that you're working on right now
well yeah we've got Fort Solace coming
up and I've got a range of audio books
that you can find me on on audible.com
and also
unbridledaudio.com I got a few things
that you might recognize the voice on
some of them cool and yeah and uh you go
on to my socials and I announce
everything else there's a feature film
coming out this year cool World War One
horror movie bunker awesome
a lot of and and we we got some short
films doing the rounds on the on the
film festival circuit too we might be
letting people have a look at them
online too if you watch this space very
cool yeah I'll leave links below to
where you can find out more from you
thank you for joining me today my friend
and uh my pleasure thanks everyone for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]